I have to ask you about live-action
Little Mermaid is there an update well
not not much yet it's just that we're
starting to write it and putting
together the script and the outline and
trying to make the adaptation from an
animated film to a to a live-action film
which is it's you know it has its unique
challenges that's for sure especially
because half the movie is underwater so
we're going to be figuring out how we do
that it's very exciting though I have to
say I want to see want to see him
dancing I'm sure you're thinking about
casting Lindsay Lohan has kind of been
petitioning to be a part of it is that a
possibility gosh I don't know who's
gonna play these roles yet we haven't
really got that far I think we're will
start that process probably this
sometime this summer you know right now
we're just focusing on the characters
the material which is everything you
know that's the most important thing in
that and then you know I have sigh I'm
starting to have some ideas but it's you
know I'm good yeah so it'll be a bit
until we get to see Ariel on the big
screen again but right now you can watch
his latest flick Mary Poppins returns on
the small screen what brings you here
after all this time same thing that
brought me the first time I have come to
look after the banks children yes you to
the home release features some
never-before-seen bonus features for
fans to see how the animation sequence
is put together that's pretty thrilling
because it starts basically in a green
room you know imagining there are
characters and you know and backgrounds
and then it comes together in this
beautiful way because it's all
hand-drawn we actually had to take a lot
of artists out of retirement to do
everything
if it'd be impossible
[Music]
let's talk about Angela why don't you go
faster me I don't think I've held a
balloon since I was a child you forgot
what it's like to hold a balloon to be a
child how did that cameo come to be well
we knew we needed to cast this amazing
part of the balloon lady which is in the
books I knew it had to be someone who
immediately could be magical you could
immediately see something special about
her and I honestly only thought of
Angela I just thought who can do that
there's no one like her she's an
original the way Dick Van Dyke is sold
by the lines over your pea soup ah you
must choose to be in the future ahead
you get really emotional in that scene
you couldn't even say cut what was that
day like on set that was a dream coming
true
to work with him let me use my hero he
leads his life I mean it's such a
beautiful lesson it's actually the
lesson of the film the message of the
film about leading life and looking at
life as a child through a child's eyes
and approaching life with Wonder and joy
and music and and magic and that's what
he does in his own life and he actually
grabbed me as we were walking on to the
set and he'd grabbed my arm and he said
I feel the same spirit here on this set
as I did on the first film so that full
circle for me was unbelievable yeah no
wonder your emotions fantastic well I
don't know I mean I will say there is a
lot of great material there there really
is I mean there are eight books there's
beautiful characters fabulous adventures
P L Travers wrote until she was I think
in her 80s and so it's you know it's all
there I hope it's not another 54 years
for the next one
puppets who came back you seem hardly to
have aged at all really one never
discusses a woman's age Michael